What were you doing alone?
I'm weird. I'm
already weird,
but it's nice to be a little weird. It's
not like something happened or anything like that." Or rather, if
Mr. Sawada is weird,
what will happen? I'll give you
this. It
tastes like a stag beetle. Mr.
Sawada says no.  It's okay. I'll
get it. You know, stag beetles are popular. I wonder if I'm too close to
my
3rd graders.
What's wrong with being so close?
My 2nd graders don't have many friends, so,
oh, that's painful. What do you say? It's half the price.  That's
true.Girls harden easily,
so it seems like it's okay.It's okay to be in pain
in Mr. Sawada's classroom.It's painful,
but it's still okay.If you don't have
fun,
come and say it's not fun.We're not Mr. Sawada
's classmates, so we'll just listen to what you have to say.
All I can do is
thank you so much
[Music]